you know there's our little pasta baby
we're breathing life into this thing
keep watching you'll see what happens
suspenseful what's up everyone i'm chef
joe sasto and today i am playing a game
called make it pasta where we have this
mystery wheel here i'm going to spin it
and then turn whatever that is into
pasta give it a whirl huh
apple pie apple pie is iconic i'm okay
with that one i'm into it i feel it
let's get some apple pie and give it a
little taste test
[Music]
so we have our pie here classic we all
know what's in an apple pie we got our
apple cinnamon sugar butter pie crust i
mean i could cut myself a slice
or i could just go right into the center
it's my pie i make my own decisions
nice sweetness on the apple it's not too
sugary
soft still got a little bit of crunch i
could do something with that gears are
turning i know what we're going to do
let's make it pasta
first things first here we got to make a
pasta dough i have an idea for this i've
made plenty of pasta doughs but i
haven't done one quite like this using
pie crust but i have an idea i think
it's going to work i'm going to start by
kind of dissecting
part of my pie here pulling just this
lattice
crust from the top
and i'm going to put that into a food
processor i don't want any apples so pie
crust pasta dough super authentic you
can probably find this nowhere in italy
so we got flour
double o our pie crust we'll go here i'm
going to use all this flour because
we're kind of staying in that apple pie
world i got a little bit of cinnamon
so our dough is going to have like a
hint of cinnamon just a little kiss i
have some dry milk powder here kind of
like carrying those flavors i feel like
with a dessert pasta some milk powder be
nice get that flavor of milk in there
put a little bit of salt you always want
some salt in pasta dough then we're
gonna throw the lid on and get all that
pie crust broken up before we add our
eggs
all right i feel good about that
actually
that already smells really nice crust is
like blooming in there we got our flour
base
and then just like all pasta doughs
we're gonna work in a little bit of egg
so i'm gonna go mostly yolks and then
some whole eggs to bring it together
starting with just the yolks
one at a time and i wish i could say i
had a recipe for this but honestly i'm
just we're making it up as we go this
isn't staged there's no swaps this is
happening this is real life so now we go
whole egg
let's go another whole egg
you can see the dough's coming together
let's stop and check the hydration here
oh look at that i think we might be on
our way to pasta dough all right let's
get all this stuff out of the way and
we'll start kneading
everyone's favorite part of pasta making
we gotta need this we gotta develop some
gluten so i'm gonna go right here onto
our countertop so let's bring this all
together and then just like all pasta
does we're just going to
work this kneading it
it doesn't feel too far off from a pasta
dough you know the color is a little
like untraditional in that sense
normally you got that like bright yellow
and as we keep kneading
this should smooth out and become nice
and supple
supple and smooth this is where i
normally want to throw it in a stand
mixer
let the machine do all the work but i'm
doing this for you guys
we're going to do this all by hand fatso
mono
that's our little pasta baby we're
breathing life into this thing keep
watching you'll see what happens
so we're getting a little smoother all
the way around there we got our apple
pie pasta dough i'm gonna wrap this up
we're gonna set this aside to rest and
now it's time to get started on the
filling
let's do it now this i'm very excited
for because i feel like it could be used
for more than just a pasta filling we
got our luscious yummy apple pie filling
we'll go all the apples
down into the food processor to kind of
like bulk this up make sure i have
enough for all my pasta add a nice kind
of creamy richness to it i'm gonna go
one of my favorite pasta filling bases
we'll go a little bit of ricotta some
mascarpone cheese so essentially we're
making a apple
ricotta cannoli filling a little bit of
salt i'm gonna use some vanilla bean
paste
you could use vanilla bean extract you
could use vanilla beans now we got
powdered sugar just to sweeten things up
in there i know there's already sugar on
the apples but we got those two new
cheeses in here that can be a little
bland i don't want it to be savory we're
going sweet pasta dolce
dessert pasta and yes for all of you
italians out there sweet pasta is a
thing
trust me on that one
look at that
i mean that's pasta filling let's give
it a quick little taste
i'm just gonna go drink this no actually
we're gonna put it into a piping bag and
then i want we'll make one more
component for our pasta i'm gonna use
the rest of that crust to make a crumble
rumble topping
let's make some streusel so if you know
me you know i'm a big fan of some
crumble rumble i like texture now in the
world of apple pie i feel like they're
those two schools of thought you have
that streusely topping which some people
might call a cobbler or crumble an apple
crumble or crisp sometimes you find that
lattice crust where it's all pie dough
so i'm going to try to
fuse and mold the two together by using
my pie crust that's left over to make a
streusel like topping to go on top of
our dessert pasta sound good yeah i feel
really good about this i don't know how
do you feel so we got the rest of our
crust down into a bowl we just go a
little bit of all-purpose flour maybe a
lot of bit of all-purpose flour we're
making it up there are no recipes for
this we got some brown sugar got some
white sugar
a little pinch of salt i have melted
butter this is going to make things even
better because butter is better and more
delicious oh yeah if you want to double
down on the butter i'm not going to
judge you i support that decision one of
my favorite spices a little bit of
nutmeg
warm some things up here
we just want to give this a nice mix
crumble up
all that pie crust
i also want to eat this by the handful
but self-control all right i'm gonna
throw this onto a baking sheet i don't
mind some big chunks in there we always
break it up a little bit spread that out
so it bakes evenly i'm gonna pop this
into the oven while this is baking and
the dough is resting i have one more
thing to make this a little extra we're
gonna make a caramel sauce to drizzle on
top of our pasta
we just got some white sugar we're going
down into the bottom of a pot or pan and
we're going to let that sugar melt the
water is going to cook off the sugar is
going to start to caramelize we're going
to hit it with a little cream a little
butter make it nice and luscious
don't have the perfect topping for our
pasta
sugar is caramelized we got that dark
amber things are going to get wild real
quick as soon as we add this cream
so cream is in there our pan has cooled
down caramel is on its way we'll add a
little bit of butter
i'm gonna season this up with a little
salt a little bit of salt and sweet
things make them taste sweeter
a little bit of sugar and savory things
make them taste more savory and we're
just using that carry over heat
to melt in our butter
look at that salted caramel who doesn't
love apples and caramel so this we're
just going to put here in our bowl and
save until we're ready it's like a
caramel hot tub in there time to make
some pasta bring this all together
our dough has been resting we can remove
it here
from our wrap
look at that pasta dough and we're done
that's it we could all go home no just
kidding we'll turn it into pasta shapes
now we'll get a little bit of flour down
this is my favorite part i always like
to start it off just with the rolling
pin
to get us going i'm gonna go split it in
half
so i'm gonna keep this in here
just so it doesn't dry out
[Applause]
there we go
our apple pie cinnamon crust pasta dough
a combination of words i didn't think i
would ever say out loud and yet here we
are now all we got to do is get this cut
up into pieces
and make some caramel
and you know what before anyone asks all
this trim we're going to eat it we're
making chef snacks we're not wasting
anything
everybody calm down
i'm a professional all right
so we have our
apple pie filling
give this a little spray that's going to
help us seal our dough
for everybody following along
you're folding over the rectangle
i want to seal down that first
notch or flap
combining the two layers into one
folding that over itself then we're
gonna seal the sides again now combining
the four layers down into two so our
thicknesses cook well and then we're
just pinching up and squeezing the sides
to flare out the ends like a candy
wrapper i like everything you know the
more you practice the better you get
the moment i've been waiting for
hopefully we've all been waiting for
we're going to cook these plate these
and give them an official taste test
just like the start of every really
great thing we're going to make some
brown butter here let's get a nice
little
couple of tablespoons down in the bottom
of the pan and you know what if you're
at home and you want to make this a la
mode
i support that decision so we've got our
butter heating up the water is going to
evaporate those milk solids are going to
separate they're going to float to the
bottom of the pan all that's going to
start to toast and caramelize and right
before our eyes will have brown butter
we're getting all this beautiful
wonderful nutty flavor we'll keep it on
the lighter side of brown butter set
this aside boil some water and cook some
pasta
boiling water a little bit of salt in
this case i don't need it like totally
seasoned as if i was cooking a savory
pasta but a little bit of salt goes a
long way we will drop our nudes down
there
go needs go now fresh pasta only is
going to take a couple of minutes as
soon as we see these float we should be
able to go right into our brown butter
caramel and the butter and a little bit
of that starchy pasta water emulsify
together with the brown butter as soon
as we see this come up to a nice little
sizzle everybody's married and happy and
romantic together in the pan we have
ourselves a plate of
apple
pie
pasta i almost forgot what we were
making for a second we got ourselves
some pasta dolce my friends here we go
caramelise i'm gonna plate this real
nice
we'll go right down the center of the
plate
a little bit of that brown butter sauce
be sure to find the biggest spoon that
you can i want caramel next
we got that salted caramel a little
drizzle we don't want it to be too sweet
we have our streusel crumble rumble here
look how that turned out i'll do just a
few crumbled up
kind of over the top it smells like
apple pie like apple pie just came out
of the oven except it just came out of
the pasta pot and then because what is
any fancy dessert nothing without a
little bit of mint i'm gonna pick off
some of these little baby leaves just
add a little bit of color
a little greenery for the scenery all
right check this out we have our apple
pie caramel our salted caramel apple pie
streusel alex we need to get her in here
to taste this
surprise welcome
so we have i'm not even gonna tell you
what it is
they are little candies they're called
caramel it's the shape of the pasta
we landed on an ingredient i'm not gonna
tell you
what the ingredient or thing was okay
i'm so excited so you get to try it
i haven't been
dying to try your pasta i'm glad to hear
that i think i'm now like the official
taste tester of tasty i love it
it's less work for me what does it smell
like tell us any guesses based on smells
smells oh
butter butter yes there's butter we have
my favorite food
oh my god
it's fantastic the thing is i know that
it's a dessert pasta but you nailed the
balance between the salty sweet not too
much it's not very much no it's apple
pie nailed it apple pie yes
good high five yes high five thank you
all the credit for this appreciate it
and you guys thank you for watching let
me know down in the comments what i
should make into pasta next this was a
curveball i wouldn't be able to do this
good luck i would love to watch you i
can do this
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you